فكره تجميع الكهرباء من الالواح الشمسيه
في الفضاء واعاده ارسالها الى الارض تعود
الى اكثر من قرن من الزمان لكنها كانت
مجرد خيال علمي واليوم تصبح واقعا
السعوديه وبريطانيا تعتزمان اطلاق مشروع
مشترك لانتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه النظيفه
في الفضاء الخارجي ومن ثم نقلها الى الارض
للاستفاده منها ذلك المشروع الطموح جدا
سيوفر مصدرا مستمرا للطاقها على مدار
الساعات الاربعه والعشرين ساعه يوميا دون
انتاج اي مواد ملوثه للبيئه
حسب التفاصيله كشفتها ديلي ميل البريطانيه
فان المشروع المشترك ستقوم بتنفيذه شركه
سبيسولر البريطانيه كل حال مزيد عن تفاصيل
هذا المشروع مع كلامس
يتضمن المشروع السعودي البريطاني وضع
الواح شمسيه في مدار الارض يتم تجميعها
بواسطه الروبوتات يتم تحويل الكهرباء الى
موجات راديو عاليه التردد تنتقل الى سطح
الكره الارضيه
وبالعوده الى الارض فان هوائيا شبيها
بالشبكه يبلغ عرضها عده اميال ومربوط بين
القطبين سيقوم بتحويل الموجات الراديويه
القادمه من الفضاء الى كهرباء ويتغلب وضع
الالواح الشمسيه على قمر صناعي على
المشكله التي تواجهها الالواح الشمسيه على
الارض الفيوم كلها هذه الالوان التقاط
اشعه الشمس على مدار 24 ساعه لما يعمل على
توفير مصدر مستمر للطاقه في جميع الظروف
الجويه تم تخصيص اربع فاصل ثلاثه مليون
دولار امريكي في الوقت الراهن لتطوير
المشروع الا ان التكلفه الاجماليه للمشروع
ستكون اكثر بكثير وستصل الى عشرات
المليارات وفقا لدراسه الجدول الخاصه بهذا
المشروع والتي قدرت انه يمكن ان يكتمل
بحلول عام
على كل من الكويت ينضم لنا الدكتور محمد
قاسم الاستاذ المساعد بكليه الدراسات
التكنولوجيا سابقا الدكتور سعد صباحك اهلا
بك مشروع والاوبل من نوعه في العالم لنقل
الكهرباء من الفضاء الى الارض عبر الوحش
شمسيه حدثنا اكثر عن هذا المشروع اهميته
دكتور
يا اهلا وسهلا فيكم صباح الخير طبعا
الفكره انه راح يكون هناك مثل القمر صناعي
جيو ستيشنري يعني ثابت مع مدار الارض
وهذا القمر الصناعي هو ليس قمر صناعي
باسلوب التقليدي انما همم
اجهزه تجمع اشعه الشمس
وحجمها اكبر من برج خليفه مرتين حجمها
هائل جدا هذا فقط في القطر في القطر
الدائري اللي يجمع الشمس تجمع اشعه الشمس
ثم ترسلها الى الارض عن طريق اشعه
المايكرويف والى نقطه محدده
مساحتها تقريبا خمسه كيلو متر بحيث ان
تجمع اشعه همم المايكرويف وتعطي طاقه
قدمها اثنين جيجا والذي يغذي تقريبا
مليون ونصف بيت طبعا على حسب البيوت
البريطانيه ولا ليس على حسب البيوت
الموجوده
فقط نفهم تغطيه اليوم عندما بنحكي عن
الالواح الشمسيه المجمعه من الشمس من
الفضاء كم المده الزمنيه اللي ممكن انه
تغطيها لفتره من الزمن هذه الشمس الماخوذه
من الفضاء
وايضا المساحه الجغرافيه التي يمكن ان
تغتيها
طبعا احنا نعرف ان عندنا مشكله المشكله ان
النصف الوقت عاده الالواح الشمسيه اللي
موجوده على الارض ظلام الليل فلذلك لا
تجمع بينما اللي موجود في السماء اللي راح
يكون في
القضاء الخارجي لن تحد اي مشاكل لا غيوم
ولا نهار عفوا الليل فلذلك سيجمع اشعه
الشمس باستمرار وتظل هذه الاشعه موجهه
تماما الى الارض على مساحه تقريبا خمسه
كيلو متر مربع فتجمع اشعه الشمس طبعا هي
الاشعه اللي جايه من القمر الصناعي هذا
راح تكون تقرير يعني مثل اشعه المايكرويف
لكن خفيفه جدا بحيث تكون منخفضه حتى اقل
من اشعه الشمس لكن لان عندنا طاقه عاليه
جدا او على مساحه كبيره فنستطيع ان نجمع
همم كهرباء اكثر طيب
على عكس الارض بامكان هذه الوحشيه تستفيد
من طاقه الشمس في الفضاء حتى في ساعات
الليل وفي كل الظروف الى اي مدى هذا مهم
لتغذيه كل العالم بالطاقه الشمسيه وماذا
عن منطقه نفقه
طبعا بكل تاكيد مساله تغذيه الطاقه لكل
عالم ليست مساله ممكن تنحلها في الفضاء
الخارجي تماما هناك حلول متعدده يعني حتى
الالواح الشمسيه على الارض لا زال تعتبر
همم طريقه لحل هذه المشكله ولذلك احنا ما
نعول على الفضاء بالكامل لكن هذه التقنيه
توفر طاقه مستمره للارض وطبعا حتى للخليج
يعني في المستقبل اذا تم هذا المشروع وفي
سنه 2040 تقريبا كما هو يعني مخطط لها اذا
صار هذا الشيء لا ادري مدى امكانيه ان هذه
الطاقه فعلا توفر كهرباء للمنطقه خصوصا
نحن مستهلكين للطاقه بشكل كبير جدا
بالمقارنه مثلا مع البيوت البريطانيه فهل
هذه راح تكون مناسبه لنا همم نحن اولاد
هذا سيظهر في المستقبل لكن بالنسبه لليوم
السعوديه بالتحديد لان المدينه ستبنى
بطريقه بحيث انها لا تصرف طاقه كبيره فقد
يكون هذا مناسب لهم تماما دكتور محمد
هي الفضائيه نفس حجم الطاقه يعني ولا اكبر
مقرر ان ما قررناها بالواح الموجوده على
الارض وهل التركيب لهذه الالواح بحكمها
وبطبيعه الحال مختلفه عن تركيب الاملاح
الموجوده على الارض
طبعا بكل تاكيد الالواح اللي موجوده في
السماء راح تكون مختلفه عن اللي موجوده في
الارض ولكن للعلم يعني هي ستكون طاقتها
اقل من طاقه الشمس الموجهه للالواح
الشمسيه اللي موجوده على الارض فلذلك هي
الفكره ليست فيها انها تجمع طاقه كبيره
وترسلها للارض يعني هناك عده مشاكل ارسال
الطاقه نفسها هذا يعني يهجر الطاقه ولكن
الفكره انه حتى تصل هذه الاشعه اللي هي
اشعه المايكرويف الى الارض لا يريدون ان
يضروا بشيء يعني تخيل ممكن طياره تمر
وتتاذى لكن لان الطاقه منخفضه اللي جايه
من الفضاء فلن تتاثر الكائنات الحيه اللي
موجوده على الارض ولن يتاثر شيء لذلك هي
اقل من الالواح الشمسيه اللي موجوده على
الارض لكن الميزه الاساسيه وجود طاقه
مستمره على مدار الساعه شكرا جزيلا دكتور
محمد قاسم استاذ استاذ مساعد بكليه
الدراسات السابقه شكرا دكتور